der meteorit der in flensburg nach einem
feuerball am himmel gefunden wurde ist
absolut unglaubliche besteht aus einem
wirklich extrem seltenen material laut
einem forschungsteam aus münster handelt
es sich um einen echten zitat
sensations- methoden fall der uns
spannende erkenntnisse zur frühphase des
sonnensystems liefert denn bisher gibt
es weltweit nur zwei andere solcher
methoden ein spezieller
sonderforschungsbereich kümmert sich
jetzt um den prozess zum science fiction
hier gibt es spannendes seines videos
aber nicht den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen es war eine
wirklich spektakuläre immerhin sie
erscheinen im september des vergangenen
jahres 2009 10 am himmel über
norddeutschland war ein feuerball zu
sehen der von einem lauten knall
begleitet wurde und vielen menschen den
atem raubte einen tag später spürte ein
mann in seinem garten in flensburg einen
kleinen dunklen stein auf sein gewicht
24 anhalt gramm und tatsächlich es
handelte sich um einen überrest vom
vortag der name des meteoriten rest
flensburg sowie der fundort an wirklich
spektakulärer fund wir jetzt die analyse
eines großen forschungsteams offenbart
etwa 15 forschungsinstitute sind
mittlerweile bei der untersuchung des
meteoriten beteiligt der kleine stein
wurde chemische und mineralogische ins
visier genommen und die ergebnisse sind
wirklich verblüffend demnach handelt es
sich um einen meteoriten der sich stark
von den meisten bislang aufgespürten
meteoriten unterscheidet konkret handelt
es sich um einen dritten mit der
gratifikation c1 unendlichen kann nur
mit sogenannten kollegen schon dritten
und das hat möglich seltenheitswert
bislang sind nur sehr wenige methoden
mit vergleichbaren eigenschaften bekannt
und die wurden achtung auf dem mond und
in der antarktis aufgespürt deswegen
bezeichnet das münsteraner
forschungsteam das ganze als ein zitat
sensations- meteoriten fallanalysen mit
dem rasterelektronenmikroskop nämlich
haben gezeigt dass flensburg nur mineral
enthält die sich in der frühphase
unseres sonnensystems gebildet haben und
zwar unter der beteiligung von wasser
unter fachleuten ist von granaten und
schicht silikaten die rede flensburg
stammt demnach
wohl von einem ursprünglichen mutter
körper der als teil eines möglichen
bausteins der erde angesehen werden kann
dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
addi bischoff der meteorit und rendsburg
gehört einer extrem seltenen methoden
klasse an und ist der bisher einzige
methoden fall in deutschland der beweis
dass es vor 45 6 milliarden jahren im
frühen sonnensystem kleine körper
gegeben haben muss auf denen dass
flüssiges wasser gab vielleicht haben
solche körper der erde auch das wasser
geliefert heißt also dass meteoriten
spannende und wichtige aufschlüsse über
die entstehung von planeten geben und
genau damit beschäftigt sich der
sonderforschungsbereich der aus
wissenschaftler innen aus berlin und
münster besteht die bezeichnung trr 170
später aggression auf der rest zwischen
planeten und diese arbeit wird auch von
der deutschen forschungsgemeinschaft
gefördert die zentralen rätsel die ihr
endlich gelöst werden sollen lauten aus
welchen bausteinen wurden planeten und
vor allem auch die erde ursprünglich mal
gebildet und hat manches material die
erde erst nachträglich erreicht und wie
war dieses zusammengesetzt antworten auf
diese spannenden fragen können vor allem
die analysen von medien geben denn die
gelten als die ältesten gesteine des
sonnensystems was ist eigentlich ein
meteorit und was ein asteroid und was na
ja und so weiter und so fort hier gibt
es die erklärung kosmisches lexikon
eines meteoriten meteoriten und
asteroiden anklicken anschauen und egis
kosmos abonnieren meine kanal empfehlung
bis dann bleibt dran